the best news for all MCU fans whether
you wanted to hear it or not was the
announcement from Marvel Studios that
they were going to be delaying a ton of
movies in 2024 pushing them back to 2025
or even 2026 they delayed so many
projects that the only movie we have
coming out in 2024 is Deadpool 3 but the
reason that Marvel Studios had for
delaying all of these projects should
make all MCU fans pretty happy they did
this so the films could be better and
not just a little bit better but much
better some movies were even completely
scrapped and started over from scratch
take Captain America Brave New World for
example they are rewriting the script
they are doing a ton of re-shoot and the
reason for this is they looked at what
they had so far and decided this isn't
good enough so it is sad that all these
movies have been delayed but it's also a
really good thing because the fact that
they are delayed means that they should
be improved and I specifically say
should here we'll see what actually
happens but thanks to all of these
delays the schedule is a little mixed up
now and a lot of people are wondering
well where is Marvel Studios at right
now with all of these projects what are
their status updates and that's what
we'll break down for you in this video
and of course if you're new to the
channel and you love Marvel be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest MCU news so with the
strikes happening and with all of Marvel
Studios delays fans kind of have no idea
what is going on right now with filming
or scheduling or pre-production
post-production it is lot but don't
worry we've got you covered now if you
haven't heard recently Deadpool 3 is
done Ryan Reynolds the other day
announced they are officially done
filming Deadpool 3 now here's the really
cool thing about Deadpool 3 like I
mentioned this is the only movie coming
out in 2024 from Marvel Studios and that
is because they have faith in this movie
they know the script is good they have
seen what they have filmed already and
they believe that what they have is
really good and here's something that's
really cool Insider Casey Walsh has
recently stated that all the shots and
sequences were locked down much earlier
than previous films to allow the CGI
teams time if they need to change things
this was a big problem for a lot of
Marvel Studios projects in the past I'm
sure if you've been following the MCU
you have noticed the CGI has been
lacking in a few different projects this
could also be the cause of a bad script
re-shoot so it's really great that
Deadpool has locked everything already
and now they are moving into
post-production it's very clear that
Marvel Studios and Disney have a lot of
conf confidence in Deadpool 3 so that is
done they are now in the editing process
and the rumor going around is that we
should expect to see the first Deadpool
3 teaser trailer during the Super bowl
next month then we have Wonderman and no
the show has not been cancelled Yaya
Abdul matin II will be Simon Williams
AKA Wonderman and in the show he will be
an actor/ stump person who gained
superpowers along the way he will not
have superpowers originally however
thanks to his Fame as portraying a
superhero a lot of people will actually
think he is a superhero which he is not
but he becomes later on they have
officially started refilm this series in
La which means we could be looking at a
2025 release date 2024 could be possible
depending on what they've already shot
so far but as of right now we are
expecting 2025 then we have Daredevil
born again they have officially
restarted shooting in New York City and
this is another one of those projects
that was unfortunately delayed but for a
good reason and Marvel Studios basically
did the same thing that they did with
some other projects they took a look at
the script they took a look at what they
had so far and decided you know what
this is not really that good and
hopefully they realized that they have a
lot to live up to because the Daredevil
Show on Netflix is truly loved by fans
and they must obviously realize this
because they promoted the heck out of
Daredevil being an echo and he really
wasn't an echo only for like a minute
but they knew people people love
Daredevil so they promoted the heck out
of it but it looks like everything now
is locked down and they have a very
clear Vision on what they want this show
to be they did scrap a lot of the script
that they had for Daredevil Born Again
originally but they did keep some of it
and we are expecting the show to come
out in 2025 assuming all things go
according to plan now that they've
picked up filming again then we have the
Thunderbolts another project that was
delayed from 2024 to 2025 this project
unfortunately has recently lost Steven
Yun as Century however the latest
casting report comes from Daniel rpk in
which he stated in a tweet in
collaboration with DCU leaks I can
report that Lewis pman has the current
offer for Century in Thunderbolts if
you're not sure who Lewis Pullman is he
played Bob in Top Gun Maverick an
amazing movie and he did an incredible
job with his role what's really
interesting is I can actually picture
him as Century with really long blond
hair and if he bulks up of course but I
actually think this might be pretty
decent casting and they need to cast
somebody 4th Century relatively soon
because the Thunderbolts is supposed to
begin filming before April so we really
don't have that much time left now it
seems like they have a pretty decent
story ready for the Thunderbolts film
obviously the story is going to involve
centy one of the strongest characters in
Marvel history the man with the power of
1 million exploding Suns but it's also
supposed to explore what they are
calling tyut Island remember the big old
Celestial sticking out of Earth now well
the MCU is finally going to address that
we haven't really had that address since
the eternals and apparently tiamut is
made out of adamantium which many people
know is the metal that Wolverine has
inside of his body that his claws are
made of so this movie has pretty big
implications for the entirety of the MCU
plus the future this could introduce the
weapon x program and could even start to
set up Wolverine the new Wolverine that
is the new one coming to the MCU
obviously not Hugh Jackman's MCU because
he's already been set up and he's from
Another Universe then we have Captain
America for Brave New World I heard some
things about what the previous movie was
supposed to be and why they are changing
it and let me just say I approve of them
basically rewriting the script this
movie kind of already has it rough
because it's another Captain America
movie but with a new Captain America
it's no longer Chris Evans don't get me
wrong I love Anthony Mackey I really
like Sam Wilson but he's got some pretty
big shoes to fill the great thing about
this movie is we are indeed going to see
Red Hulk Thunderbolt Ross will be red
Hulk in this film and this film actually
does have more implications for the
weapon x program as well because we do
know that they are still experimenting
with people with the super soldier serum
and other ways so perhaps this could be
the start of the weapon x program as
well now according to Charles Murphy at
Murphy Multiverse decom this is going to
restart when the new script is ready he
says hopefully by mid 2024 and I do like
this I like that they're not really
starting until they have a complete
script finished because that is how you
make a better movie we'll talk more
about this in another video that I have
coming up soon then the news that a lot
of people are waiting for Fantastic 4
according to Charles Murphy this is
going to begin filming in summer of 2024
now according to some other insiders an
announcement of the official fantastic
forecast is imminent and we've heard
from director Matt shakman recently who
stated that he really does want to tell
us soon we have heard the cast is
officially locked in that Marvel Studios
has their fantastic forecast everybody
and that means that it's going to get
out eventually it's probably going to
get out pretty soon so Marvel Studios is
going to probably want to make the first
move and officially announce it we've
talked about this in several videos but
basically once they begin filming people
are going to take photos of them
Paparazzi and leak them online so we
should be getting that official casting
announcement pretty soon now next is a
project that has undergone a lot of
changes and we are talking about blade
this movie I believe has had four
rewrites and I'm super glad that they
did because according to reports mahel
Ali really didn't even like the script
to begin with and I'm actually really
glad he hasn't left this project because
I think he's going to make a great blade
based off of what we know about the film
and where it's currently at there's a
new script and Mersa Ali is actually
satisfied with it so finally yet again
they are moving forward with a script
that is supposed to be pretty good
fingers crossed at least now last but
not least we have of course have to talk
about Avengers 5 there have been some
conflicting reports from different
insiders about what Marvel studios's
plans are for Kang but most of the
Insiders have reported that Marvel
Studios is indeed going to keep King the
Conqueror or at least a Kang variant as
the main villain for Avengers Secret
Wars however most of the reports are
stating that Kang is no longer going to
be the villain of Avengers 5 hence why
they changed it from Avengers the King
Dynasty to Avengers 5 that is according
according to a report from The Hollywood
Reporter now according to Charles Murphy
this is tentatively stated to begin
filming in 2024 this year late 2024
however and we most likely are going to
be getting this film in 2026 which is
basically what has been reported so
unfortunately we'll have to wait a
couple of years to get Avengers 5 but we
do want Marvel Studios to do the best
they can with this film obviously and
this is a focus of them right now what
do they do with the next Avengers film
do they put King in it do they not do
they let the whole John Anan Major's
trial di down so people aren't thinking
about it and to do that they have to not
mention Kang or do they simply recast
have Kang still be the villain of
Avengers 5 and keep it King Dynasty
based off of what we've heard they've
already decided to move away from it
being called King Dynasty again
according to the Hollywood Reporter
which would mean they have to come up
with a pretty new script they may not
have to scrap everything but we know a
good amount of the script is going to be
changed but they're on it because it's
supposed to begin filming at the end of
this year which means they have a decent
ENT time to lock everything down and
make an incredible script and these are
basically all of the big projects that
are going to be happening with the
remainder of Phase 5 and the beginning
of Phase 6 so there's an update for you
about where everything is at right now
again the delays suck but it's great
news to hear that they really are taking
their time with these projects trying to
make good movies and shows and of course
we have Deadpool 3 coming out this year
which is supposed to be huge so let me
know your thoughts about all of this in
the comments down below please don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
to stay up on the MCU and if you
subscribe and leave a comment you're
automatically entered in our giveaway
for a chance to win Xbox series X A PS5
some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items we pick one winner at the end of
each month and they pick one item you
can find us on Instagram and Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
woof